let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 let's start today with our caller
from the 9 7 8
area code who's calling today from 9 7 8
hi it's Tom I'm just outside the Boston
area hey Tom what's up hey Farrell a
show by the way thank you um I was just
wondering your opinion of Marty's
governor rather than mayor of Boston in
terms of what he's been doing with the
virus and Emmett yeah yeah you know
here's the thing
I've been going basically by Charlie
Baker the governor's guidelines and so
I'm embarrassed to say I don't know
whether whether mayor the mayor has put
in place stricter guidelines or not like
we can are you up to speed on what he's
done I did go for a walk the other day
and in a sort of more touristy area
there was like a family of tourists who
were taking pictures and stuff and it's
like the streets were empty and
everything was closed but it was funny
because they were sort of acting like
everything was normal and I was
wondering you know that that's just kind
of interesting to be doing that at this
point in time they weren't doing
anything wrong they were walking outside
like everybody and keeping their
distance but they were doing all the
touristy stuff near the common it was
kind of weird to see and I think that's
fine you know I've been on some of the
bike paths in different spots and people
you do sometimes get people that are
pretty close to each other when they
pass but the doctor I interviewed
earlier during the week said the odds of
transmission when you're doing that are
so so so low even if one of the people
was sick which of course really you know
uh there's there's asymptomatic people
but people should know if you're feeling
anything you should be staying at home
anyway right yeah yeah no I completely
agree oh thanks again I keep doing the
good work all right Tom Tom from outside
Boston great to hear from you